[Música]
hola muy bienvenidos a 5 minutos con en
lo que va del año 2021 más de 3400 niñas
adolescentes y también mujeres han sido
reportadas como desaparecidas en perú lo
que representa un aumento del 16% frente
al mismo período del año anterior esta
alarmante cifra fue presentada por la
defensoría del pueblo de perú y para
analizar esta problemática conectamos ya
mismo con eliana revollar adjunta para
los derechos de la mujer en la
defensoría del pueblo de perú eliana
revollar muchísimas gracias y bienvenida
a france en 24 bueno los datos oficiales
indican que existe un promedio de 16
desapariciones por día y una cada 90
minutos en perú a qué se debe una cifra
tan alarmante
santiago buenos días efectivamente la
defensoría del pueblo en el perú desde
el año 2020 viene sacando reportes que
son reportes mensuales de lo que está
pasando con las denuncias de
desaparición de mujeres en todo el ciclo
de vida esta es una situación que nos
preocupa porque hemos pedido que haya
modificaciones legales en el perú
tenemos un sistema nacional de
desaparición de personas y la defensoría
lo que hace es
captar las notas de alerta que lanza la
policía nacional del perú para la
búsqueda de las mujeres en este sentido
tenemos que decir que las denuncias aún
son mayores a las notas de alerta que se
lanzan por ejemplo en el año 2020 se ha
terminado con un promedio de 10 mil
denuncias de las cuales han habido
5500 notas de alerta entonces sí es un
problema porque no se sabe a ciencia
cierta cuántas mujeres continúan en esa
situación de desaparición porque todavía
no tiene el registro una información que
pueda retirar aquellos casos en los que
ellas han aparecido sea vivas o sin vida
porque muchas de ellas han sido víctimas
por ejemplo el feminicidio bueno un poco
lo estaba adelantando y si bien usted
decía bueno que no se sabe dónde están
según ha analizado cuáles podrían ser
los fines de estas desapariciones
precisamente la defensoría tiene dos
hipótesis no en el caso de las mujeres y
adolescentes que es la mayor prevalencia
de desapariciones estamos hablando por
ejemplo entre enero y julio que ha
ocurrido en este grupo etáreo de un
promedio de
363 desapariciones sin embargo si
consideramos todos los menores de edad
incluidos los varones son 417 entonces
un
87% es de niñas púberes o adolescentes
entonces si cruza una variable de edad y
de género de ellas y nosotros hemos
sabido que muchas de ellas son captadas
por redes de personas que se dedican a
la trata a personas que se dedican a la
explotación sexual pero muchas de ellas
también huyen de escenarios de violencia
en sus hogares ya veces en lugares donde
las violentas física y psicológica o
hasta sexualmente entonces lo que es la
defensoría exige es que desde el
ministerio interior que es el ente
rector haya un estudio criminológico
para saber qué es lo que está pasando
cuáles son las causas y consecuencias
porque lo que sí cruza es la violencia
que puede ser causa para que ellas se
expongan a una exposición o consecuencia
para ser víctimas de delitos que tienen
que ver con su condición de mujeres ya
que atribuye no que sean las mujeres las
más afectadas
un estudio desarrollado por la
defensoría del pueblo del perú en el año
2020 justamente nos llevaba a considerar
esas dos variables el hecho de que sean
mujeres tiene que ver con la
discriminación estructural que tiene la
mujer en el país y por qué es alta
prevalencia desapariciones han habido
casos como lo decía por ejemplo de
mujeres un
24% de 138 feminicidios en el 2020 y de
92 9 en este año 10 por ciento antes se
denunciaron como desaparición no hay una
correlación todavía en el perú del
número de desapariciones que habrían
desembocado en casos penales de trata de
personas por explotación sexual por
ejemplo pero si hay una alta prevalencia
de esa condición de mujeres que son
víctimas de escenarios de violencia o
que han sido víctimas de otro tipo de
delitos sean agresiones sexuales las han
secuestrado privado de libertad las han
sometido a distintos tratos rebollar
muchísimas gracias a la debo interrumpir
se nos acaba el tiempo muchísimas
gracias por su testimonio ha sido un
placer tenerla en france 24 a nuestra
audiencia como siempre la invitamos a
continuar informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y en france24 punto
com sigan con nosotros
[Música]